I've never used cocaine, heroin or crystal meth because I get addicted to things very quickly
And I don't want to change into one of * these * people
Hi! May I still have some drugs?
Do you have money?
Not really ... But I really like those drugs!
No man, no money, no drugs
That is just how the economy works
Oh my God please!
No!
Very much please !?
Please please please !!! I really enjoyed those drugs! Please give me a little more drugs!
Shut up!
Alsjeblieeeeeeeeeffffffftttt! No! Please! No! Please! Shut up! PLEASE!
NO! Fuck bitch!
GIVE ME THE MOTHERFUCKING DRUGS YOU MOTHERFUCKING BUCKLE BEFORE I SHOOT YOU A MOTHERFUCKING BULLET THROUGH YOUR MOTHERFUCKING BRAIN
But do you know what has always been my first choice for drugs?
~ Organize ~
Yes you are, you understood me well
I am certainly 100% addicted to ~ organizing ~
Facebook event ... * Is online *
Anime club ... * Sent *
Sunday society ... * Check *
* No idea what that chick is saying but it is probably not very relevant *
HMHMHM HEU
...Oh no...
THERE IS NIKS MORE TO ORGANIZE
Oh no no no no ... there must be SOMETHING to organize!
Just a little something! I just want to organize one more thing! Just one! Another one!
I don't know exactly why, but I just really enjoyed it
And I am not only very excited
But ... Also a bit excited;)
As a teenager I always went to Office Max
And I almost finished when I looked at all rows of folders, color-coordinated folders and pens and the whiteboards with grilles on them that were arranged per month
Hmmmmm yeahhh ... Mama likes that ...
I know this video is pretty weird
But I really enjoy organizing
4 months ago I was organizing an event that would take place in April
So next month
And I made the mistake of organizing this much too late in the evening
Because that meant I couldn't sleep anymore
I was just so fucking excited
OMG what goodies will I bring ?!
Oh I'm going to bring meals every night!
We really have to have a taco evening everyone loves tacos ...
Oh yes but then I have to know everyone's diet in case someone eats gluten free or dairy free or something ...
Ohhhh and carpooling! OHHH
That will be so much fun!
Will I allocate a room based on personality to everyone, or will I just let everyone choose for themselves?
Omg there is so much to organize
THAT MUCH
Omg omg I have three months to make all these decisions!
And you? Do you have this too?
Is this something that all type A people have?
I just feel so satisfied when I have control over all these chaotic elements
And to merge everything into one specific place and time
I just feel like a God
I'm Anna Akana, stay awesome Gotham
* licky licky * ♪♪